ah welcome captain those slacks are a
knockout come on I trust you found my
home easy to locate and thank you all
for wearing appropriate Footwear
wow you really let your hair down when
you're not at the office ah detectives
meet my husband Kevin evening so glad
you could make it I'm look he brought us
some wine drink this is legally called
wine drink how very thoughtful thank you
it's red like blood you know I worked a
double homicide on this block a couple
of years ago the details will astound
yes I'm sorry
perhaps Raymond didn't say anything our
home has a no shoptalk policy I don't
bring home Beowulf and he doesn't bring
home cop stories so may I pour you some
of this wine drink you brought us
perhaps all of it all of it sounds good
Tom Haverford my name is Trevor Nelson I
represent a client who would like to
make you an offer
baby-faced heard my demo I will accept a
record deal no you deeply misunderstand
my client has taken an interest in
rent-a-swag he'd like to know if you are
looking to sell it
controlling interest in this door whoa
Diddy wants to buy rent-a-swag not what
I said this is a lot to process will did
he be coming to the meeting mm-hmm I'm
not at liberty to tell you who my client
is it would violate confidentiality I
understand it's not Diddy okay
[Music]
[Music]
Shawn oh my oh sorry I wasn't here to
greet you aya had something I needed to
tend to it they can wait they can wait
okay I've hacked into the mainframe
kidding
I can't hack into the mainframe
technically I am the mainframe oh just
hurry up
I'm here to rule on the fate of fake
Eleanor she'll stroke yes yes um I think
we have a rock-solid case for fake
Eleanor I truly believe she's a good
person are you sure because I believe
she's stealing my train going out into
public is a huge risk so maybe let's go
over some self-defense techniques
oh sure you warn somebody before you do
that Raymond told me that the element of
surprise was crucial cool yeah
so he's a great teacher but I will say
this if you're gonna do a throat punch
it is key that you say something cool
afterwards like choke on that right but
they're not choking they're experiencing
airway trauma oh how about better get
some corticosteroids to treat that
laryngeal fracture okay yeah that's very
informative and quite polite but maybe
add a dirt bag on the end a dirt bag is
a useful part of a vacuum I don't see
how it's an insult sorry
you know puncher's choice moving on
we're gonna need disguises and since
we're going to a public library the best
way to fit in is as scholars weird
perverts
yes weird perverse is far better far
better
[Music]
alright this let me do the talkin here
okay I mean he's a lawyer I'm an
accountant we speak the same language I
mean obviously accountants are a little
more bad-boy but there's a respect there
when will this be over hey Trevor I've
been talking to Ron about estate
planning and he is here to do some Good
Will Hunting he has to draw up a new
will so yes I understand house do I
thank you as I've said before I just
don't like puns no no my accountant
friends seem to enjoy mr. Swanson let's
begin by filling up his form listing
your assets and liabilities nice try I'm
not telling you how much money I have
where it's hidden or which precious
metals and/or gemstones it may or may
not take the form of if you don't give
me the information I need there's
nothing I can do I'm come on Trevor
where there's a will there's a way I'm
gonna say this one last time wait
check the accountant crap at the door
yes sir I will the bad place has sent
bad Janet to present their argument what
up ding-dongs yeah so basically on the
fake Elinor's a dirtbag and liesje
boonies are gonna try and claim she's
less of a dirtbag now but she just stole
your train and she still sucks bad and
she belongs with us
Oh also check this out nailed it
I've ruled the fart inadmissible as
evidence what I will consider is the
recent development of Eleanor stealing
my train now hold on a second she stole
your train to voluntarily go down to the
bad place
she was sacrificing herself because she
is a wonderful selfless don't don't
worry what's happening I should have
warned you Sean only cares about cold
hard facts if he attacks any feelings in
your voice he retreats into a cocoon so
what we need to do now is just be very
still very quiet
[Music]
finally because they're also perfect
what did the efficients say when you got
married not much when gay marriage was
legalized we weren't sure if or when it
was gonna be struck down so speed was of
the essence do you Kevin yes and to you
yes yes we do we're married I remarked
afterwards that I wished the officiant
had been more efficient it was very
funny Kevin still talks about it
maybe I should open with that zinger
Benjamin after thinking about what you
said I've decided to leave each of my
children 5 percent of my fortune Wow 5
whole percent so I guess you are gonna
teach them a lesson
oh my god that's 5 percent that is a lot
of money wait is this a joke it is not a
joke
not that an accountant wouldn't know the
difference also if something should
happen to Diana and me we decided that
the kids should go to the most important
people in our lives I'm I'm incredibly
flattered Ralph piotrowski and his wife
Helen he's the maitre d at Mulligan's
Steakhouse and he knows me better than
anyone however if they are not able to
do it which seems likely is they're in
their 90's you and Leslie are choice
number two I'm honored I gotta hand it
to you captain that was some ceremony
but it wasn't difficult I simply said
what I wish had been said when Kevin and
I got married and I never would have
heard your hilarious
efficient efficient quit you're right I
regret nothing but all this does make me
think I might enjoy a more festive
expression of our commitment to one
another are you suggesting we hold an
honest-to-goodness wedding nothing too
elaborate
we're not the Kardashian West's after
all they are musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
I know they were entered on Jeopardy I
think you mean questions
you guys are fine and finally here is a
check for the entirety of the purchase
of Renta swag and here is a personal
note from my client dr. Saperstein dear
Tom I win you suck turn note over you
still suck turn note over okay
Saperstein couldn't even face me himself
he had to send in his Lackey my client
isn't at this meeting because he doesn't
have to be successful people mr.
Haverford use their money to get others
to work for them mmm it's an interesting
idea lawyer dude what if I give you five
bucks put it back a poop in Saperstein
scar no ballpark me how much would it
cost $10,000 and in an even weirder way
I think I might actually miss you huh
and in an even weirder way I want you
guys to be my dad's that is weirder yeah
I got stuff I brought you your box would
be the AIDS you know yeah look at about
this one we never watched Captain
Corelli's Mandolin what the hell did you
just say Captain Corelli's Mandolin say
that to my face captain growlers
pennilyn it was a movie about a mandolin
and you kept it from me for two months I
didn't think it was any good it's just
some period piece set in grease oh my
wrap terribly sorry it has been a very
trying time yeah next thing you're gonna
say you wish me had watched leaving Las
Vegas the dark ponderous reflection on
Alcoholism that are in cages Oscar
oh cool when I'm even partway through
the door to the afterlife my powers come
back they do they do thanks for asking
[Music]
we did it Oh what no yeah no of course
of course Janet did it yes but I have
the Thank You Janet how did you get down
here we have the only key to the door to
earth we built our own door that's
impossible
that's impossible yeah well you're such
a dweeb why can't you leave us alone you
don't have enough nostrils to stuff with
wasps I don't want just any wasp
nostrils I want these wasp nostrils
you're just delaying the inevitable
Michael the bad place is going to get
all of them eventually these for their
loved ones even your precious peepee
King Doug for said now why would you
think that just a hunch and do you want
to know what else I had a hunch about No
[Music]
you